doing it God the setup for this just was
so intense that I am not ready to do
this yes I am psyched just kidding you
got prank so hard haha hi my name is
very Saba you did not know now you know
your life is different now
it is now October which means it's one
of the scariest time of the year it's
election season and Halloween season so
today I wanted to make something
inspired by both Halloween and the
election season caramel apples caramel
apples are a staple of fall that was the
end of that sentence and around
Halloween a lot of people make scary
caramel apples but because this election
season is extremely important and
extremely terrifying instead of scary
caramel apples I'm going to make scary
harmful apples follow along okay I found
a recipe on Pinterest and the first
thing I need are 12 whole apples I have
six wash and dry apples done these
apples are cleaner than my person right
now like and subscribe
insert sticks insert sex innuendo
popsicle sticks I got them okay
jiangha ow great I'm just Oh watch out
sexual this is heading
[Music]
Wow and that is what sex is like we got
all the sticks in these apples then what
happens heat all ingredients except
vanilla in a heavy two quart saucepan
over medium-low heat stir constantly he
know who likes to stir constantly King
Donald Trump give us some intelligent
conversation stop stirring the [ __ ]
pot haha medium-low heat
let us all that's with a beat drop 1/4
cup of butter that sounds delicious 1
cup white syrup d Trump did you get this
recipe I'm assuming it's like corn syrup
because that's what I found on a lot of
other recipes for caramel apples this
recipe I'm using is grandma Betty's
caramel apples grandma Betty like Donald
Trump listen one cup of this white syrup
this is also the amount of hair gel that
the hair stylist uses for Donald Trump
before the base that's in 14 ounces of
condensed milk whoa 2 cups of white
granulated sugar keep my cabinets close
I don't want to show you guys everything
in honor of Trump you know I'm not
measuring things in the right things but
trying but all of that is in key all
ingredients stir constantly I'm supposed
to heat the caramel until it reaches the
soft ball stage 235 degrees Fahrenheit
of 240 degrees Fahrenheit and that made
me just realize that I forgot to buy a
candy thermometer looks like I won't
have the right temperament your
temperature
welcome back you miss my incredible joke
dog this is my impression of Melania
Trump getting pleasured by Donald Trump
because Carmel's almost done so this
says take it off the heat and let it
rest for a little bit
oh I have to add the vanilla bamm-bamm
whoa oh damn it smells so good they need
a buttered baking sheet at the ready
are you ready great it says using the
stick inserting the apples dunk Apple in
the hot caramel and twist slowly away
from the heat dunk it and then you twist
it oh my god this looks like a caramel
apple okay now I put it on this baking
sheet we let it harden let me continue
to do that same thing touched it and it
burned me so I imagine anyone hugging
Donald Trump sounds like afterwards five
is good five is like the number of
fingers on one of Donald Trump's tiny
hands I didn't say it back check it
Internet let's clean this up a little
bit okay
it's Donald Trump ringtone our harmful
apples have started to drive for a
little bit and now is the time in which
we decorate them I got some classic
candy corn I'm going to start there I am
living against Donald Trump standards of
women I use my mouth for something other
than complaining I'm just going to put
these candy corn while the caramels
still a little bit soft right in the
middle ha ha our candy corn is now
attached to our harmful apples the next
thing I want to do is there's all this
green natural apple color next to the
stick and I want to cover that up and so
I thought I would use creamy supreme
cream cheese frosting very white color I
want to make it a little bit more golden
then I'm gonna take some yellow food
coloring here we go yeah we mix it up
there we go it's still blowing out you
can't tell now we take a sandwich bed
now wait dump this into it okay we're
going to try and turn this into a cake
frosting pipette bag one of those bags
where you can like pipe out all the cake
frosting I know that that did not
further define what that was and we snip
off the corner I'm gonna cover the tops
of this thing sort of up this doesn't
really do anything and you have to be
precise you just want to cover the green
part cover anything that is organic or
natural or real and take some icing from
the ones that have a little bit too much
and move it over to the one that doesn't
have enough really sharing that well
something polar opposite what I'll jump
ever believes now we clean up hawala
here's our final product are scary
harmful apples if you didn't guess it
already these apples are very much made
to resemble Donald Trump you can see
they're almost identical to the real
thing skin color hair color I added you
know it's classic bloodshot eye nose
there is a mouth on these harmful apples
because I just didn't want to and some
of you might be saying like oh that's
scary but what's so harmful I did add
some actual quotes from Donald Trump
that he has said pretty recently I just
rolled out some fondant icing and I used
an edible marker and wrote some quotes
that Donald Trump has actually said over
the past few years let's take a look at
what we got here if Hillary Clinton
can't satisfy her husband what makes her
think she can satisfy America that's a
great number-one priority I'll take
advantage of the laws of the nation
because I'm running a company so
relatable I'll build a great great wall
on our southern border and I will have
Mexico pay for that wall Wow
you know we got some sexism some racism
and a little side of just pure
unadulterated delusion and narcissism
what more can you ask for in a candidate
that's gonna run the United States of
America everything you're gonna ask for
everything more you can actually choose
everything more because you get to vote
if you live in the United States please
please dear God vote if you can please
dear God vote if you can I begged it's
it's it's it's just so important and
there you go that's it for this episode
if you like this video give it a thumbs
up and subscribe to this youtube channel
because not everything is political here
but for right now I have to be harmful
attitudes can infect this
and we have the opportunity to not allow
that whoo I don't know Donald Trump
she's on Hilary's marriage to Bill
Clinton but like has anyone put Melania
under a lie-detector test to ask her if
she's being weakened at Bernie's but who
am I to judge their relationship they're
just two people that have never been
actually loved by anyone in their lives
coming together to run the free world oh
my god